This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Nearly half a century ago, volunteers in a psychological experiment were shown a slight show of a small red car getting into a crash. Some volunteers were asked, how fast was the car traveling when it passed the yield sign? There was a catch. The original slides showed the car passing a stop sign, not a yield sign. Psychologists Elizabeth Lafterson, her colleagues, later asked volunteers to identify images they had seen before. Some volunteers were shown the earlier slide with a stop sign. Others saw an edited slide where the stop sign was replaced by a yield sign. Volunteers who had been asked the question about the yield sign mistakenly remembered seeing the picture with the yield sign.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。大约半个世纪前，在一项心理学实验中，志愿者们观看了一段小红车发生碰撞的微型幻灯片。一些志愿者被问到：当汽车经过让行标志时，它开得有多快？这里有个陷阱。原始幻灯片显示的是汽车经过停止标志，而不是让行标志。心理学家伊丽莎白·洛夫图斯和她的同事后来要求志愿者辨认他们以前看过的图片。一些志愿者看到了带有停止标志的早期幻灯片。另一些志愿者看到的则是经过编辑的幻灯片，其中停止标志被替换成了让行标志。那些被问及让行标志问题的志愿者，错误地记成了自己见过带有让行标志的图片。
In the intervening decades, hundreds of experiments have shown that what we think we see is really an amalgam of what is out there, how we feel about what we see, our conversations with others about what we see, and so on. Attention, memory, and emotion all play a role in shaping what we notice and what we fail to observe. In the late 1990s, the psychologist Dan Simons and Christopher Shibri devised an experiment that produced a nearly unbelievable result.
在随后的几十年里，数百项实验表明，我们自认为看到的东西，实际上是客观存在的事物、我们对所见事物的感受、我们与他人关于所见事物的讨论等各种因素的结合体。注意力、记忆力和情感都在塑造我们注意到什么以及我们未能观察到什么方面发挥着作用。在上世纪90年代末，心理学家丹·西蒙斯和克里斯托弗·查布里斯设计了一项实验，产生了一个几乎令人难以置信的结果。
They had volunteers watch a group of people passing basketballs. Volunteers were told to count how many times the ball was passed between members of a group. It was tricky, but if you focused, you could do it. But the researchers were after something more interesting than counting basketball passes in a video. A person wearing a full gorilla suit walks into the middle of the video, turns to face the camera, thumps its chest, and then walks off the other side about 9 seconds later. The gorilla seems impossible to miss.
他们让志愿者观看一群人传接篮球。志愿者被告知要数一数球在团队成员之间传了多少次。这很棘手，但如果你集中注意力，就能做到。不过，研究人员追寻的东西比数视频中的篮球传球次数更有趣。一个穿着全套大猩猩服饰的人走进了视频正中央，转身面对镜头，捶胸顿足，然后在大约9秒后从另一侧走开。这只大猩猩似乎是不可能被漏掉的。
It's a gorilla. But as psychologists Dan Simon points out, the volunteers were not looking for gorillas. They were intently counting basket-ball passes. What we find is about half the people who view this video didn't notice the gorilla. And when you ask them about it, they're shocked that they could have possibly missed something so obvious. This week on Hidden Brain, why we miss things hiding in plain sight and how grifters and cheats take advantage of our blind spots. We'll also explore how to keep from falling prey to scams.
这是一只大猩猩。但正如心理学家丹·西蒙所指出的那样，志愿者们并不是在找大猩猩。他们正全神贯注地数篮球传球次数。我们发现，大约有一半看这段视频的人没有注意到这只大猩猩。而当你问他们这件事时，他们感到很震惊，觉得自己怎么可能会漏掉这么显眼的东西。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨为什么我们会忽视藏在眼皮底下的东西，以及骗子和小偷是如何利用我们的盲区的。我们还将探讨如何避免沦为诈骗的受害者。
In daily life, all of us deal with a barrage of emails, texts and calls. Most are from coworkers, friends and family, but every so often, someone reaches out with a more sinister agenda. At the University of Illinois, Urbana, Champagne, psychologists Dan Simon studies how our perception, attention and memory are fallible and vulnerable to exploitation. Dan Simons, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me on. I want to play you a clip from a story that appeared some time ago on NPR.
在日常生活中，我们所有人都应对着大量的电子邮件、短信和电话。大多数来自同事、朋友和家人，但每隔一段时间，就会有人带着更险恶的动机联系你。在伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校，心理学家丹·西蒙研究了我们的感知、注意力和记忆力是如何不可靠且容易被利用的。丹·西蒙斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我来。我想给你听一段前不久在NPR播出的一篇报道中的音频。
Take a listen to the clip. You were in an orchestra that played music on tour, 2002 to 2006, but the music you played was not with the audience heard. That's right. I am a pretty good amateur high school violinist, but when I performed for this orchestra, the microphone in front of me was off, and a CD recording of a much more talented violinist was being blasted towards unsuspecting audiences. So Dan, what is the story about? Well, this is a story that's based on a memoir from Jessica Hinden, who's a creative writing
听听这段音频。你在一个在2002年至2006年期间随团巡演并演奏音乐的乐团里，但你们演奏的音乐并不是观众听到的。没错。我是一名挺不错的高中业余小提琴手，但当我为这个乐团演出时，我面前的麦克风是关着的，而一个更有天赋的小提琴手的CD录音正对着毫无防备的观众大声播放。那么丹，这个故事到底是关于什么的呢？嗯，这个故事是根据杰西卡·辛登的回忆录改编的，她是一位创意写作
professor, and also an amateur quasi-professional violinist that we first read about in an article that was in the Guardian, a newspaper that talked about, I faked, in a world-class orchestra. It was essentially the headline of the article. And in the original story in the Guardian, she talked about how she performed as part of this ensemble that would travel around, and it was performed with somebody who was a famous composer. And she would pretend to play the violin
教授，也是一位业余的准专业小提琴手，我们最早是在《卫报》上的一篇文章中读到这个故事的，这家报纸讨论了“我在世界级乐团中造假”的话题。这基本上就是那篇文章的标题。在《卫报》的原始报道中，她谈到了自己是如何作为这个四处巡演的乐团成员进行演出的，而且演出是与某个著名作曲家合作的。她会假装拉小提琴
when in reality the music that was being played was a CD being played over speakers. I want you to stop a moment and imagine the scene. An amateur violinist somehow infiltrates a world-class orchestra. In front of live audiences, she pretends to play the works of a famous composer while music from a CD blasts out on speakers. Picture the scene in your mind.
而实际上正在播放的音乐是通过扬声器播放的CD。我想让你停顿片刻，想象一下这个场景。一个业余小提琴手不知怎么混进了一个世界级乐团。在现场观众面前，她假装演奏著名作曲家的作品，而扬声器里则轰鸣着CD里的音乐。在脑海中想象这个场景。
Where is this happening? What would you see if you were in the audience? What would it take for you to notice the fake boasting king? Dan was fascinated by the story in part because of his interest in scams, but there was also something about it that didn't seem to add up. My first thought when I read that was, no way. If you know anything about musical performances, orchestras are loud. The music comes from all over the place in a world class. Orchestra will be performing in a world class concert hall. So it's really hard to imagine that many musicians faking in sync with each other to a CD and having nobody in the audience often often very musically knowledgeable people,
这是在哪里发生的？如果你在观众席上，你会看到什么？你需要付出什么才能注意到那个虚张声势的骗局？丹对这个故事着迷，部分原因是他对骗局感兴趣，但其中也有一些地方似乎说不通。我读到这个故事时的第一反应是，绝不可能。如果你对音乐演出有所了解，乐团的声音是很大的。音乐来自世界级乐团的四面八方，他们将在世界级的音乐厅里演出。所以真的很难想象会有那么多音乐家跟着CD整齐划一地假奏，而且观众席上的任何人——通常往往是非常懂音乐的人——
be able to tell. I mean, think of it this way. It's hard to fake symbols clashing, right? The timing has to be perfect or you notice the discrepancy. So that immediately, for me, raised red flags, okay, what's going on here? Maybe this is an unreliable narrator, right?
竟然都察觉不出来。我的意思是，换个角度想。要假装钹的撞击声是很难的，对吧？时机必须完美，否则你就会注意到不一致的地方。所以对我来说，这立刻敲响了警钟，好吧，这里面有什么不对劲？也许这是一个不可靠的叙述者，对吧？
This is a creative writing professor, writing about a memoir. We know that memoirs often have distortions in them. So we started doing a lot of digging into this story. And identified the composer as Tim Janis, who is a new age composer. We did a little digging into him and it turns out that Tim Janis had an ensemble. He actually had about a dozen copies of this ensemble, traveling around to state
这是一位创意写作教授，在写回忆录。我们知道回忆录中往往会有失真。所以我们开始对这个故事进行深入挖掘。并确认这位作曲家是蒂姆·詹尼斯，他是一位新世纪音乐作曲家。我们对他的背景做了一点调查，结果发现蒂姆·詹尼斯有一个乐团。他实际上拥有大约一打这样的乐团副本，四处奔波于州立
fairs and mall court yards, performing new age music that sounds like Titanic. So it was often a violinist, maybe a keyboardist, and a penny whistle, and nothing like a world-class orchestra. So we then said, okay, well, we've got to go read the original, go read the book, and it turns out the book is very straightforward. It really never claims that this is an orchestra. There was nothing in it that said, I performed in a world-class orchestra. The term world-class orchestra,
集市和商场中庭，演奏听起来像《泰坦尼克号》那样的新世纪音乐。所以通常是一个小提琴手、可能还有一个键盘手和一个哨笛手，这跟世界级乐团完全沾不上边。于是我们说，好吧，我们得去读读原作，去读读那本书，结果发现这本书非常直白。它其实从来没有声称这是一个乐团。里面没有任何内容说，“我在一个世界级乐团里演出”。“世界级乐团”这个词，
that came from the story in the Guardian. And as for the famous composer running this traveling ensemble of musicians, it said the composer was famous, which is true. He's a very famous new age composer. He's performed on PBS specials with George Clooney narrating, but it's new age music. It's not orchestral music.
是来自《卫报》的报道。至于那个经营这个巡回音乐家乐团的著名作曲家，书里说这位作曲家很出名，这倒是不假。他是一位非常著名的新世纪音乐作曲家。他曾在由乔治·克鲁尼担任旁白的PBS特辑中表演过，但这是新世纪音乐。它不是管弦乐。
And of course, if you're performing, if you're doing this at a state fair, presumably with three participants, and there's a lot of other stuff going on, people are walking around, there's a lot of noise. Now it's much easier to play a piece of music from a CD player. And even if people knew that it was coming from the CD player, they probably wouldn't look twice.
当然，如果你在演出，如果你是在州立集市上做这件事，大概有三个人参与，而且周围还有很多其他的事情在发生，人们走来走去，有很多噪音。现在，从CD播放器里播放一首乐曲要容易得多。而且即使人们知道声音来自CD播放器，他们可能也不会多看一眼。
They wouldn't look twice, and they probably wouldn't care. It's also the case that in a mall context with all of that background noise, you can blast the speaker loud enough that you really probably couldn't tell whether the music was coming from that one violin and that one pennilessle player. Dan could now see how one piece of suggestive but inaccurate information, the use of the
他们不会多看一眼，也可能根本不在乎。另外，在商场这种背景噪音很大的环境中，你可以把扬声器开得足够大声，以至于你大概真的无法分辨音乐究竟是来自那把小提琴和那个哨笛手。丹现在明白了一条暗示性但不准确的信息——即使用了
word orchestra, triggered a whole cascade of assumptions in his head. Those assumptions, of course, turned out to be inaccurate. So this was a case in which we were completely fooled, not by the work itself, but by the headline. You hear famous composer and immediately assume classical composer. And if it's a world-famous classical composer, of course a world-famous classical composer is going to be leading over an out orchestra. So it makes it reasonable to make that conclusion and to draw in the most readers possible. And then that gets perpetuated over time.
“乐团”这个词——是如何在他脑海中引发一连串假设的。当然，这些假设后来被证明是不准确的。所以这是一个我们被彻底愚弄的案例，不是被作品本身，而是被标题愚弄了。你听到“著名作曲家”就会立刻联想到古典音乐作曲家。如果是一位世界著名的古典音乐作曲家，那么世界著名的古典音乐作曲家当然会领导一个管弦乐团。因此，得出这个结论并尽可能吸引最多的读者是合乎逻辑的。然后这种看法随着时间的推移而不断延续。
And so, as we heard in that brief clip from NPR, the opening question is, so you performed in an orchestra, and that didn't get immediately corrected. Not surprising, it's hard to do that in real time. And that possibly continued to lead to this sort of dissemination of what's essentially distorted information. to lead to this sort of dissemination of what's essentially distorted information. What I find fascinating about that story is that it's a little bit like a magic trick,
因此，正如我们在NPR的那段简短音频中听到的那样，开场问题是：“那么你曾在一个乐团里演出过，”而这一点并没有被立即纠正。这并不奇怪，在实时情况下很难做到这一点。这可能继续导致了这种基本上被扭曲的信息的传播。导致这种基本上被扭曲的信息的传播。我觉得这个故事最迷人的地方在于，它有点像一个魔术，
which is that the real action with the magic trick is not happening while the magician is actually you know waving his or her arms or waving the wand dramatically. It's happening with some small thing that you're not noticing. And of course that's exactly how this worked, which is that you say famous composer and orchestra, I have in my mind, I'm thinking Carnegie Hall. I'm sort of imagining Carnegie Hall and I'm like, wow, 150 musicians sitting on a stage are faking it and they're playing the music out of a CD, play that's incredible. But of course, it comes from those associations, which are so quick and automatic, and we construct entire castles of meaning
也就是说，魔术的真正玄机并不是在魔术师实际上在（你知道的）挥舞手臂或戏剧性地挥动魔杖时发生的。它发生在某些你没有注意到的微小事情上。当然，这正是它的运作方式，也就是当你听到“著名作曲家”和“乐团”时，我的脑海里浮现出卡耐基音乐厅。我有点在想象卡耐基音乐厅，然后我想，哇，150名音乐家坐在舞台上假装演奏，他们用CD播放器放音乐，这太不可思议了。但当然，这是源于那些如此迅速且自动化的联想，我们在脑海中构建了整座意义的城堡，而我们却从未回过头去质疑它。
inside our heads that we never go back to question. Yeah, and I think what happens in cases like this is people will come to this assumption based on reading one term that's very precisely stated and then end up because of that assumption not realizing that they distorted information that they've spread something that's actually not accurate. And it's easy to do.
是的，我认为在像这样的情况下发生的事情是，人们会根据阅读一个被非常精确陈述的术语而得出这种假设，然后因为这个假设而没有意识到他们歪曲了信息，他们传播了一些其实并不准确的内容。这很容易做到。
But I think it's also just as easy for us to get really concrete specific information that we believe and forward and pass along to others because it's consistent with what we believe. This natural tendency of the mind is the same one that operates when we get taken in by scams. So we don't even really need these sort of large associations to have us fooled. We can just get something in our email or on Facebook or on social media that sounds right to us. And we tend to just sort of assume that it's true before finding out otherwise. that it's true before finding out otherwise. I understand some time ago you decided to make an investment in a company called American
但我认为，我们同样也很容易获得非常具体的、我们坚信不疑的信息，然后将其转发并传递给其他人，因为这符合我们的信念。这种人类大脑的自然倾向，与我们在陷入骗局时起作用的倾向是相同的。所以我们甚至不需要这种大型联想来愚弄我们。我们只需要在电子邮件、脸书或社交媒体上看到一条听起来对我们来说很对的信息。在弄清真相之前，我们往往会直接假设它是真的。在弄清真相之前，我们往往会直接假设它是真的。据我所知，前不久你决定投资一家名为美国生态的公司。
Eco. Tell me about the company and how that came to be. This is a classic case of how not to do investment. So this was one of the first times I ever invested in an individual stock, which I don't do at all anymore. I just go for, you know, very safe index funds. But this was a case in which I was really excited about this company because a friend of mine had told me about it, right? And this friend of mine had invested in it, had made a lot of money, it had been rising,
跟我讲讲这家公司，以及你是怎么做出这项投资的。这是一个关于如何不能进行投资的经典案例。所以这是我第一次投资个股，现在我完全不这么做了。我只选择（你知道的）非常安全的指数基金。但这却是一个我对这家公司感到非常兴奋的案例，因为我的一个朋友跟我提过它，对吧？而且我的这位朋友投资了它，赚了很多钱，它的股价一直在上涨，
and had lots of stories about what the company does. It was an environmental cleanup company. It was led by somebody who purportedly was a minister, which gave it this additional credibility. And initially it was doing well, and it was monitoring really closely. And then everything came crashing and burning down. I don't know the reasons behind why it came crashing down, but it just went bankrupt to drop to zero value.
并且有很多关于这家公司业务的故事。它是一家环境清理公司。它的领导者据称是一位牧师，这赋予了它额外的可信度。最初它表现不错，我也在密切监控。然后一切都崩溃并付之一炬了。我不知道它崩盘背后的原因是什么，但它就是破产了，价值跌到了零。
But it was a perfect case in which I heard from a friend who I trusted, who was very interested in this sort of investment, had dug into it a lot, was listening to their conference calls, and was equally snowed by it. He made a lot of money because he got in early, but this is the sort of mechanism that leads us to make a lot of terrible mistakes. So the same thing happens now with crypto investments, many of which turn out to have been frauds or scams, right?
但这却是一个完美的案例：我从一个我信任的朋友那里听说了这件事，他对这种投资非常感兴趣，深入研究过，一直在听他们的电话会议，并且同样被它蒙蔽了。他赚了很多钱，因为他入场很早，但这正是那种导致我们犯下许多严重错误的机制。所以现在加密货币投资也是如此，其中许多投资最后都被证明是欺诈或骗局，对吧？
You hear from a friend who has a way of making a quick buck. It sounds enticing. You don't know enough to check it out. You probably don't fully understand how blockchain works and how the mechanisms of this crypto coin function. But because you had somebody who was familiar to you and trusted, you said, okay, I'll do that too. And then it comes crashing down. Well, I'm sorry, you lost your investment in this company, but it does reveal an important
你从一个有快速捞钱方法的朋友那里听说此事。听起来很诱人。你对它了解不够，没有去查证。你可能并不完全理解区块链是如何运作的，以及这些加密货币的机制是如何发挥作用的。但因为你身边有一个你熟悉且信任的人，你说，好吧，那我也这么做。然后它就崩盘了。好吧，很遗憾你在这家公司的投资打了水漂，但它确实揭示了一个重要
lesson here, which is that we trust people whom we know. And in some ways, there's a very good reason for that. Our lives would be impossible if we didn't trust our friends and co-workers and family. And what you did was you extrapolated that trust probably into a domain where you should not have done so. The problem is not with the trust, but in assuming that trust carried over when it came to the land of investments.
教训，那就是我们信任我们认识的人。在某些方面，这有非常充分的理由。如果我们不信任我们的朋友、同事和家人，我们的生活将无法进行。而你所做的，可能是将这种信任外推到了一个你不应该这么做的领域。问题不在于信任本身，而在于假设这种信任在进入投资领域时依然有效。
Exactly, we have to trust people. And we trust people often because they're familiar to us. So familiarity is one of these sorts of hooks that we find really appealing. If something's familiar to us, we tend to give it more credibility. We tend to trust it more. And that makes a lot of sense, right? Because as you've gotten to know people, family, friends over time, people who have led you astray or lied to you repeatedly are no longer people you're going to associate with. So the people who are still in your circle, who are still familiar with you, who you interact with regularly, are people who've earned your trust.
没错，我们必须信任他人。而且我们信任他人往往是因为他们对我们来说很熟悉。所以熟悉感是我们觉得非常有吸引力的诱饵之一。如果某事对我们来说很熟悉，我们往往会赋予它更多的可信度。我们往往会更信任它。这非常合乎情理，对吧？因为随着时间的推移，你逐渐了解了家人、朋友，那些曾把你带入歧途或对你反复说谎的人，将不再是你交往的对象。所以那些依然在你的圈子里、对你来说依然熟悉、与你定期互动的人，都是赢得了你信任的人。
And we've learned to do that over, probably way many, many generations. The problem now is that we have a much, much larger circle of people who seem familiar to us than we might have in our past. So you might have a ton of, quote, friends on social media that you've never actually met. Yeah. You've only interacted with virtually. But because you've interacted with them in
我们大概在许多许多代人的时间里，已经学会了这样做。现在的问题是，与我们的过去相比，我们有了一个大得多的、对我们来说显得熟悉的人群圈子。所以你可能会在社交媒体上有成吨的所谓的“朋友”，而你实际上从未见过面。是的。你只在虚拟世界中与他们互动过。但因为你曾以某种
some form, you assign them that same trust you might to a closer friend. And that can lead you really wrong. So if you look at most romance scams, for example, they gradually build up that familiarity until you fully trust somebody who you've never met at all, and probably looks and sounds nothing like the person you interact with virtually. There's also the question of domain familiarity here, which is that, let's say for example, I'm speaking to you, and you're an expert in psychology or a professor at a university. But we suddenly started talking about theoretical physics, and you very confidently told me something about theoretical physics.
形式与他们互动过，你便赋予了他们那种你可能会给予更亲密朋友的信任。这会把你带向非常错误的道路。因此，如果你看看大多数杀猪盘或浪漫骗局，你会发现它们如何逐渐建立这种熟悉感，直到你完全信任一个你从未见过面的人，而这个人在外表和声音上可能跟你虚拟互动的那个人毫无相似之处。这里还有一个领域熟悉度的问题，也就是说，比方说，我在跟你说话，而你是一位心理学专家或大学教授。但我们突然开始谈论理论物理学，而你非常自信地跟我讲了一些关于理论物理学的事情。
Now I might tell myself, you know, Dan Simon's smart guy, clearly he's an academic, he's an expert in psychology. Maybe I should follow him and trust him in what he says about theoretical physics. And this is the other thing here, which is that expertise in one domain doesn't necessarily translate over to the next, but it has the feeling like it does when we talk to people whom we like and respect. Yeah. And that's when it veers into punditry when people don't actually know something about a topic, but are speaking with absolute certainty about it the same way they would their own
现在我可能会对自己说：“你知道的，丹·西蒙斯是个聪明人，显然他是个学者，是个心理学专家。也许我应该追随他，相信他对理论物理学的看法。”这就是这里的另一个问题，即在一个领域的专业知识不一定会转移到另一个领域，但当我们与我们喜欢和尊重的人交谈时，它确实给人一种可以转移的感觉。是的。而当人们对某个话题其实并不了解，却像谈论他们自己的专业
content domain. I tend to find that it goes the other way around that theoretical physicists talking about psychology, garner more trusted than probably should. But yeah, I mean, that's a danger for anybody who has become an expert in something. One thing that happens as you gain expertise is you tend to trust your intuitions and your instincts more because you've built up a lot of experience with them. And a lot of really successful people believe that they can trust their gut about everything because they've had a number of judgments happen to work out. You know, I was talking some time ago with Abidjid Banjid, he's an economist at MIT, and
领域那样信誓旦旦地发表绝对确定的言论时，这就转向了专家评说。我往往发现情况恰好相反，理论物理学家谈论心理学时获得的信任可能比他们应得的要多。但话又说回来，对任何一个在某领域成为专家的人来说，这都是一种危险。当你获得专业知识时发生的一件事是，你往往会更相信自己的直觉和本能，因为你在其中积累了大量的经验。许多非常成功的人认为他们可以相信自己对任何事情的直觉，因为他们有很多判断恰巧都奏效了。你知道的，前不久我和阿比吉特·班纳吉交谈过，他是麻省理工学院的经济学家，
he won the Nobel Prize in economics some time ago. And he was telling me that after he won the Nobel Prize, you know, it's very hard for him to be in a social setting where people don't defer to him in everyday life. I mean, people ask him his opinion, and now the Nobel Prize winner has spoken. So clearly, which movie should we go to? Which restaurant should we go to? I'm sure Abidjit knows the right answer. And so there's this domain creep that allows you to say,
前不久他还获得了诺贝尔经济学奖。他告诉我，在他获得诺贝尔经济学奖后，（你知道的）他在日常生活中很难处于一种人们不顺从他的社交场合。我的意思是，人们向他征求意见，现在诺贝尔经济学奖得主已经发言了。所以很显然，我们该去看哪部电影？我们该去哪家餐厅？我确信阿比吉特知道正确的答案。因此，这种领域蔓延允许你这样说：
because I'm an expert in one thing I'm seen as an expert in everything. Yeah, and it's a really strong temptation, probably, to have all of these people who are looking up to you as the expert on some topic. And recognizing when that expertise is limited is a real challenge. I mean, the true experts, the true really insightful people are the ones who say, I don't know, I have no idea.
因为我是某个领域的专家，我被视为所有事情的专家。是的，对于所有这些将你视为某个话题的专家并仰望你的人来说，这可能是一种非常强烈的诱惑。认识到这种专业知识的局限性是一个真正的挑战。我的意思是，真正的专家、真正具有深刻洞察力的人，是那些会说“我不知道，我毫无头脑”，
I don't know anything about that as opposed to just blustering away. When we come back, the most common types of scams and the psychological tricks they employ. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. One of the oldest legends revolves around a clever scam. In the Trojan War, Greek warriors supposedly laid siege to the city of Troy for 10 years. After much bloodshed, the Greeks pretended like they had lost the war.
“我对那个一无所知”的人，而不是只会夸夸其谈的人。广告回来后，我们将探讨最常见的诈骗类型及其采用的心理诡计。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。最古老的传说之一围绕着一场聪明的骗局展开。在特洛伊战争中，希腊勇士据称对特洛伊城进行了长达10年的围攻。在付出大量流血牺牲后，希腊人假装他们输掉了战争。
They sailed away on their boats, leaving behind a large wooden horse. The Trojans dragged the horse into their city as a trophy, not realizing that Greek soldiers were concealed inside. Once inside Troy, the Greeks laid waste to the city and won the war. At the University of Illinois Urbana-Champaign, psychologists Dan Simons has studied the psychology of scams along with a psychologist Christopher Shabri Dan and Chris are co-authors of the book nobody's fool Why we get taken in and what we can do about it?
他们乘船驶离，留下了一尊巨大的木马。特洛伊人把木马拖进他们的城市作为战利品，却没有意识到希腊士兵正藏在里面。一旦进入特洛伊，希腊人便将城市洗劫一空并赢得了战争。在伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校，心理学家丹·西蒙斯与心理学家克里斯托弗·查布里斯一起研究了诈骗心理学。丹和克里斯是图书《没人是傻瓜：我们为什么会上当受骗以及我们能做什么》的合著者。
So going back about a hundred years Dan a man named Charles Ponzi orchestrated a massive financial fraud in the 1920s Tell me the story of what he did. Ponzi's idea was that by investing in hostile coupons and dealing with exchange rates across countries, he could profit by buying in one country, selling in another country. Turns out that wasn't really doable for lots of reasons, but he'd gotten enough people to invest in this scheme that he didn't stop it right then. He continued to return money to some investors and then try and pull in more and more investors
那么回到大约一百年前，丹，一个名叫查尔斯·庞兹的人在20世纪20年代策划了一场大规模的金融欺诈。跟我讲讲他是怎么做的这个故事。庞兹的想法是，通过投资国际回信邮票券并处理不同国家的汇率，他可以通过在一个国家买入、在另一个国家卖出来获利。事实证明，由于种种原因，这其实是不可行的，但他已经吸引了足够多的人投资这个骗局，所以他当时并没有停下来。他继续向一些投资者返还资金，然后试图吸引越来越多的人
to use their money to pay the next people. So each person who was paying into this scam was paying out to the people who were in before them, which is now what's known as a Ponzi scheme. It's a pyramid scheme where the people who were in first get paid out, but then you have to bring in more and more people as investors to pay off the ones who came before you. It eventually crashes and burns when you run out of investors. But Ponzi promised huge returns in a very short window of time.
用他们的钱来支付给下一批人。因此，每个向这个骗局投钱的人都在向比他们更早加入的人支付回报，这就是现在所谓的庞兹骗局。这是一个金字塔骗局，最先加入的人会得到回报，但随后你必须引入越来越多的投资者作为资金来偿还那些在你之前加入的人。当你用完投资者时，它最终会崩溃并化为灰烬。但庞兹承诺在极短的时间内获得巨额回报。
I understand that at the time he took in something like $15 million, which must have been a boatload of money in the 1920s. Yeah, and in fact, at one point, I believe he owned a bank in order to kind of do a little bit of the money laundering directly, because it wasn't as closely regulated as it is now. What's interesting about Ponzi's scheme is that nowadays, most people would know that in a promise of 50% returns in six months with no risk whatsoever
据我所知，当时他卷入了大约1500万美元，在20世纪20年代这肯定是一笔巨款。是的，事实上，在某个时候，我记得他为了直接进行一点洗钱而拥有一家银行，因为当时的监管不像现在这么严格。关于庞兹的骗局，有趣的是，如今大多数人都知道，承诺在六个月内获得50%的回报且没有任何风险
is impossible. It's way too good to be true. But people do still fall for variants of that. We've seen that with a lot of crypto offers. They'll offer gigantic returns in a very short time frame. Anytime you get that sort of an offer, it's almost certainly a scam of some sort, whether or not it's actually a Ponzi scam. So more recently, we had the example of Bernie Madoff. I'm not quite sure if Bernie Madoff was running a pyramid scheme, but in some ways, his plan had similarities to what Ponzi was doing. Yeah, it was a Ponzi scheme in some form. He was taking in new investments to pay out old investments, but it differed in a really fundamental way. What made off offered wasn't a guarantee
是不可能的。这好得简直难以置信。但人们确实仍然会落入这种骗局的变体中。我们在许多加密货币报价中都看到了这一点。它们会在极短的时间内提供巨额回报。任何时候当你得到这种报价时，它几乎肯定是一种某种形式的骗局，无论它实际上是不是庞兹骗局。因此，更近一点，我们有伯尼·麦道夫的例子。我不太确定伯尼·麦道夫是否在经营金字塔骗局，但在某些方面，他的计划与庞兹所做的事有相似之处。是的，它在某种形式上是一个庞兹骗局。他一直在吸收新的投资来支付旧的投资，但它在一个非常根本的方面有所不同。麦道夫提供的不是
of 50% returns in six months, but what he offered was something different that investors really wanted. They wanted safety, security, and consistency. So his fund, fund in quotes there, because it wasn't actually a real fund, promised and returned 8- 14% every single year with never a down year and almost never a down month. That's really enticing to a lot of people who want that sort of regular return without the risk associated with it. He took away all the volatility
承诺在六个月内获得50%的回报，而是投资者真正想要的不同东西。他们想要安全、稳妥和一致性。所以他的基金——这里的“基金”加了引号，因为它实际上并不是一个真正的基金——承诺并做到了每一年都实现8%到14%的回报，而且从来没有出现过亏损的年份，几乎从来没有出现过亏损的月份。这对于许多想要这种常规回报而又不想承担相关风险的人来说非常有吸引力。他消除了所有的波动性，
and he claimed he could do this because he was a master at watching the market and the trading floor and he could time his trades to take advantage of that in a way that would have been superhuman. Talk about the fact that Bernie Madoff was a pillar of the community. A lot of people looked up to him,
并且他声称自己能做到这一点，是因为他是观察市场和交易大厅的高手，他能够把握交易时机来利用这一点，其方式简直超乎常人。谈谈伯尼·麦道夫是社区支柱这一事实。许多人仰慕他，
people had deep ties to him, and in many ways all of these social connections ended up exacerbating the scam. Yeah, in many ways, where the Madoff scam is what's known as an affinity scam, in that he was praying on people that were part of his social community, the Jewish philanthropic community in New York especially. And he was the head of NASDAQ before this all happened, so he was a very prominent financial
人们与他有着深厚的联系，在许多方面，所有这些社会关系最终加剧了这场骗局。是的，在很多方面，麦道夫骗局被称为“亲缘骗局”，因为他掠夺的是属于他社会群体的人，特别是纽约的犹太慈善社区。在此之前他是纳斯达克的负责人，所以他是一个非常杰出的金融
figure. He was a titan of the industry. And prior to his scam, he actually ran a legitimate business that had he just done that was highly successful, which made it harder for people to doubt him because he could speak with a lot of authority. He didn't come across this sort of brash con man. He came across as somewhat humble and understated and was very good at getting people to trust him, especially people who were associated with the groups that he associated with.
人物。他是行业巨头。而在他的骗局之前，他实际上经营着一项合法的业务，如果他只做那个的话，那也是非常成功的，这使得人们更难怀疑他，因为他可以说得很有权威。他给人的感觉不像那种厚颜无耻的骗子。他给人的印象是有点谦逊和低调，并且非常擅长让人信任他，尤其是那些与他交往的群体有关的人。
He also was selective. He wouldn't allow just anybody to invest with him. He kind of selected it and made it sort of this accomplishment to have been allowed to invest with him. So I'm picking up on sort of two psychological themes. Here one is the principle of scarcity, which is you make something scarce and it becomes people wanted more than they did before.
而且他很有选择性。他不会允许任何人跟他投资。他进行了某种挑选，并让人觉得被允许跟他投资是一种成就。所以我注意到了两种心理主题。这里一个是稀缺原则，也就是你让某样东西变得稀缺，它就会变得比以前更受人追捧。
But also, we're returning again to the same theme that we discussed earlier when you fell for something because a friend told you that an investment was a good investment, which is in this case too, people were investing with Bernie Madoff because they trusted him. They thought Bernie was my friend. Bernie's not gonna do anything to harm me.
但同时，我们再次回到了我们之前讨论过的主题：当你因为朋友告诉你某项投资是一项好投资而上当受骗时，也是这种情况，人们把钱投给伯尼·麦道夫是因为他们信任他。他们认为伯尼是我的朋友。伯尼不会做任何伤害我的事。
Exactly. And in fact, when you know somebody, and you're somewhat familiar with somebody, that's when they are going to be most able to take advantage of you, if they happen to be a con artist of that scale. And the assumption is so firmly held that it becomes a commitment,
完全正确。事实上，当你认识某人，并且对某人有一定程度的熟悉时，如果他们恰好是那种规模的骗子，那正是他们最能够利用你的时候。而这种假设是如此坚定，以至于它变成了一种承诺，
something that we no longer question. There's a great example of a financial investor who was attuned to what was going on with the made off Ponzi scheme, knew it was a scam, tried to warn a friend of his whose parents had been heavily invested in made-off and said, look, you should tell them to get out of this. This is not a good thing. And their response was, well, he just doesn't know Bernie. Bernie would never screw us. That idea that his beyond reproach is what allowed him to continue to operate the scam without being questioned.
一种我们不再去质疑的东西。有一个很好的例子，讲的是一位金融投资者，他注意到了麦道夫庞兹骗局的情况，知道这是一个骗局，试图警告他的一位朋友，他的父母在麦道夫那里投入了巨资，并说：“听着，你应该告诉他们撤出。这不是一件好事。”而他们的回应是：“噢，他只是不了解伯尼。伯尼绝不会坑我们的。”这种认为他无可指责的想法，正是他能够继续运作骗局而不受质疑的原因。
People were fully committed to it, even when they heard evidence of the contrary, wouldn't back away from it. And that's something that happens to all of us in many contexts. And that can lead to a lot of problems. It can send you down a rabbit hole that's very hard to crawl back out of because in order to undo all of the logical steps and hoops you've jumped through
人们对此深信不疑，甚至在听到相反的证据时也不愿退缩。这是我们所有人在许多情况下都会发生的事情。这会导致很多问题。它会把你带进一个很难爬出来的兔子洞，因为为了消除你为了进入那个洞而经历的所有逻辑步骤和繁文缛节，你必须重新评估你出发的地方并对其进行质疑，这是我们通常没有准备好去做的。这里有另一个沿着这些路线的例子。前不久，一位名叫伊丽莎白·霍姆斯的创业者在克林顿全球倡议组织上发表了关于她的公司正在从事的一项非凡突破的演讲。我们的工作是能够以这样一种方式让人们获得实验室检测：每个人，无论其保险状态如何，无论他们住在哪里，都负担得起进行检测的能力。
to get down that hole, you have to take a re-evaluation of the place you started and question it, something that we're generally not that prepared to do. Here's another example along those lines. Some time ago, an entrepreneur named Elizabeth Holmes spoke at the Clinton Global Initiative about an extraordinary breakthrough that her company was working on. Our work is in being able to make lab testing accessible to people in a way in which every person, irrespective of their insurance status, irrespective of where they live, can afford the ability to get a test on.
所以这意味着，在我们的案例中，我们在过去12年中投资开发了数百种检测，其中许多检测费用低于10美元。丹，这个想法有一种非常诱人的地方，因为检测，其中许多检测费用低于10美元。丹，这个想法有一种非常诱人的地方，因为如果你事实上能以极少的钱为人们检测多种疾病，那真的可以彻底革新医学治疗，特别是在贫穷国家。我能理解为什么克林顿全球倡议组织，
So that means, in our case, we've invested the last 12 years in now developing hundreds of tests, many of which are less than $10. There's something very seductive about this idea, Dan, because of tests, many of which are less than $10. There's something very seductive about this idea, Dan, because of course, if you, in fact, can test people for a number of disorders for very little money, that really could revolutionize the treatment of medicine, especially in poor countries. And I can see why the Clinton Global Initiative,
它有兴趣帮助贫穷国家的人们，为什么听到这样的信息会非常有吸引力。是的，这是一个美好的愿景，对吧，如果它是真的话。他们宣称的一个标志性特点是，他们可以用极少量的血——远少于你在进行传统检测时通常抽取血样所需的量——通过一台可以随身携带的小型化检测机器检测400种甚至可能超过一千种不同的东西，而其他类型的传统检测则需要巨大的机器和大量的血液，这在某种程度上解释了为什么风险投资家想要直接加入
which is interested in helping people in poor countries, why this could be very appealing to hear a message like this. Yeah, it's a beautiful vision, right, if it were true. And one of the things that was a homework of their claims was that they could, with a single small amount of blood, much less than you would typically take in a blood draw to do traditional testing, could test 400s or possibly even more than a thousand different things with a miniaturized testing machine that could be moved around, whereas other sort of traditional testing would require giant machines, larger amounts of blood, which in some extent explains why venture capitalists wanted to jump right
进来。这也解释了为什么前军事领导人对它感到兴奋，因为这里有潜力做这样一件事：你可以在现场进行血液检测，而不必将其送回传统实验室。因此，伊丽莎白·霍姆斯的“热拉诺斯”公司最终倒闭了，但再次强调，我想在这里停留片刻讨论心理学概念，也就是在这个案例中，公司愿景的理想主义是人们不像他们应该的那样持怀疑态度的原因之一，因为当然，你不想去质疑这是否可能，因为事实上它将帮助那么多的人，包括穷人。这感觉像是一件崇高的事情。嗯，这确实是一件崇高的事情。
in. It explains why former military leaders were excited about it, because here's the potential to do something where you could do blood testing in the field, as opposed to having to send it back to a traditional lab. So Elizabeth Holmes' company, Farah Nose, eventually went out of business, but again, I want to stay with for a moment with the psychological idea here, which is, in this case, the idealism of the vision of the company was one reason why people were not as skeptical as they should be, because of course, you didn't want to question whether this was possible, because in fact it was going to help so many people including poor people. It felt like something that was noble to do. Well, and it would be something that was noble to do.
这个使命，这个想法是崇高的，当然这也是许多骗局的标志。它会带来如此惊人的结果。你所需要做的就是在这里投入一点资金，对吧？它也符合硅谷的炒作周期，即承诺那些实际上最终没有做到他们声称已经做到的产品，对吧？所以它更符合那种模式，而不是医疗器械模式和生物检测模式，后者通常不具备那种标志，对吧？你通常必须在获得大量资金之前证明它。所以关于这一点有趣的一件事情是，是的，它对那些思考如何使用这项技术、它会有多大益处的人产生了巨大的吸引力，但对生物技术专家却没有那么大吸引力。因此，如果你看看热拉诺斯公司的董事会，里面坐满了退役将军、退役海军上将、前国务卿，都是真正成就斐然、成功的人士，但他们都没有生物技术方面的特定培训。而资助热拉诺斯的大部分资金来自硅谷的风险投资公司，而不是东海岸的生物技术界和投资公司。这背后是有充分理由的，对吧？
The mission, the idea of it was noble, which of course is also a hallmark of a lot of scams. It's going to be this amazing result. All you have to do is put in a little money here, right? And it also fit into the Silicon Valley hype cycle of promising products that don't actually eventually do what they claim to have done, right? So it fit more into that mold as opposed to the medical devices mold and the biological testing mold, which doesn't tend to have that hallmark, right? You normally have to prove it before you can get a lot of money. So one thing that's interesting about this is, yeah, it had a tremendous
那些投资医疗技术、身为生物技术专家的业内人士会彻底核查这类说法，他们大多数人可能心知肚明。仅凭针刺取血就能做到这一切，实在是有些天方夜谭。重大声称伴随重大后果，需要极其强有力的证据。你在书中谈到了另外两个非常有趣的骗局。跟我讲讲总统骗局。哦，是的。这是我最喜欢的骗局之一。这是一个由一个名叫吉尔伯特·
amount of appeal to people who thought about how they could use this technology, how much benefit it would be, but not so much to biotech experts. So if you look at the Board of Directors of Theranos, it was filled with retired generals, retired admirals, former secretaries of state, really accomplished successful people, but people who had no specific training in biotech. And most of the money that's funded Theranos came from Silicon Valley venture capital firms, not from the East Coast biotech world, and investment firms. And there's a good reason for that, right?
希克利的人发起的骗局，他是一个法以混血骗子。他承认自己基本上创造了这个骗局。他会做的是，他会打电话给一家公司的中层管理者。比如一家区域性银行的经理。然后他会假装自己是整个银行连锁网络的行长。所以那个区域性银行经理可能知道行长是谁，但并不是密友。
The people who invest in medical technologies, who are experts in biotech, would thoroughly check those sorts of claims out, and most of them probably knew. That's pretty far out there to be able to do all of this with a pinprick of blood. And big claims with big consequences require really strong evidence. You talk about two other scams in the book that I really interesting. Tell me about the president scam. Oh, yeah. This is one of my favorites. It's, this was a con initiated by a man named Gilbert
他们在层级中处于足够低的位置，不一定能很好地认识那个人。但他会做的是，他会打电话给他们并告诉他们：“嘿，我正在与法国政府合作，我们在调查协助恐怖分子的嫌疑人，特勤局已经在你们银行分行识别出了几个可能与恐怖分子资助挂钩的账户。所以你在接下来的一個小时左右会接到一个特勤局特工的电话，我需要你以他们需要的任何方式全力协助他们。”当然，打电话的并不是银行分行的行长，
Schickley, who's a French Israeli con artist. And he has admitted to essentially creating this scam. What he would do is he would call up, say, a middle manager at a company. So let's say the manager of a regional bank. And he would pretend to be the president of the entire bank chain. So that regional bank manager probably knew who the president was, but wasn't a close colleague.
而是吉尔伯特·希克利，但如果银行分行经理相信这就是他所说的那个人——而我们往往有一种默认偏见，即在有理由质疑之前接受我们听到的事情是真的——那么他们就完蛋了。于是特勤局特工打来电话，我们或许应该再次澄清，他自称为保罗，并说：“好的，（你知道的）我们需要你去买一部新手机，因为你的手机不安全，并且让这个靶子卷入了骗局中，对吧？”他们成为了这种想法的参与者：他们认为自己在协助政府进行一项秘密行动，而且他们不能把这件事告诉任何人。最后，他让这位银行经理从账户里提取了数十万欧元的现金
They were far enough down the hierarchy that they wouldn't necessarily know that person well. But what he'd do is he'd call them up and tell them, hey, I'm working with the French government and we're investigating people who are aiding terrorists and the secret service has identified a couple of accounts at your bank branch that may be tied to funding of terrorists. So you're going to get a call from a secret service agent in the next hour or so and I want you to help them in any way that they need. Of course, it wasn't the president of the bank branch.
他们在层级中地位较低，不一定很熟悉那个人。但他的做法是打电话给他们，告诉他们，嘿，我正在与法国政府合作，我们正在调查协助恐怖分子的嫌疑人，特勤局已经确定了你们银行分行的几个账户，可能与资助恐怖分子有关。所以你们在接下来的一小时左右会接到一个特勤局特工的电话，我希望你们全力配合他们。当然，打电话的并不是银行分行的行长。
It was Jovera Shikli, but the bank branch manager, if they trusted that this was who he said he was, and we tend to have a default bias to accept what we hear is true unless we have reason to question it, then they're lost. So the secret service agent calls, and it's probably we should clear again, calls himself Paul and says, okay, you know, we're going to need you to go get new phone because yours is not secure and involves the mark in the con, right? They become a participant in this idea that they're helping the government with a secret operation and they can't tell anybody about it. So in the end, he gets this bank manager to withdraw hundreds of thousands of euros from
打电话的是约维拉·希克利，但银行分行经理如果相信这就是他所说的那个人，而且我们往往有一种默认偏见，即在没有理由质疑之前，倾向于接受我们听到的话是真的，那么他们就输了。于是特勤局特工打来电话，我们可能应该再次澄清，他自称保罗，并说，好吧，你知道的，我们需要你去买一部新手机，因为你的手机不安全，这涉及骗局中的“受害者”，对吧？他们参与了“协助政府进行秘密行动”这一想法，并且不能告诉任何人。最后，他让这位银行经理提取了数十万欧元。
the bank, claiming that they're being withdrawn from a known account, taking it to a cafe, handing over a bag of cash to somebody so that that person can then go and mark the bills and bring them back, and then, of course, they're gone. So, you know, if you're the bank manager, if anybody stopped and told you from the outset, hey, look, how odd would it be for a bank manager to withdraw 300,000 euros from your own bank, stick it in a bag and then hand it to somebody? Outside of the bank in a cafe, any bank manager would say, well, that's got to be scam. But in the moment, when you have bought into that initial statement that this was the president, then you've been hooked.
这家银行声称这笔钱是从一个已知账户中提取的，然后他们把钱带到一家咖啡馆，把一袋现金交个某人，这样那个人就可以去标记这些钞票并把它们带回来，当然，然后他们就消失了。所以，你知道的，如果你是银行经理，如果一开始有人拦住你并告诉你，嘿，你看，一个银行经理从你自己的银行提取300,000欧元，把它塞进一个袋子里，然后把它交给某人，这会有多奇怪？在银行外面的咖啡馆里，任何银行经理都会说，嗯，那一定是个骗局。但当时，当你相信了最初的那个声明——这就是总统本人时，你就已经上钩了。
You know, if you're the middle manager, you know, it would take some gumption to say, you know, I don't know who you are. Let me call you back to confirm that you are the president. You know, that would be very rude if you are a middle manager speaking to the president of your bank. Exactly. That's the real challenge. That's why it's so effective. It's coming from a position of authority and typically a trusted authority. There's a modern variant of the president's scam that's much dumber, that's pervasive now.
你知道的，如果你是个中层经理，你知道的，要想说“我不知道你是谁，让我回个电话确认你是总统”，这需要一些胆量。你知道的，如果你是一个与银行行长交谈的中层经理，那会非常粗鲁。确实如此。这才是真正的挑战。这就是它如此有效的原因。它来自于一个权威的立场，通常是一个值得信赖的权威。总统骗局现在有一种更愚蠢的现代变体，现在无处不在。
And if you work in an organization, you may well have already gotten emails from your company's CEO or president or your department head saying, hey, I'm in a meeting, but I need you to Finalize this transaction or I need you to pay this invoice really quick if you happen to be the business manager who gets those sorts of messages or emails regularly You probably won't think twice about it But once the business email has been compromised so that they know who to send it to in the right sort of way, it's very hard to question that. I have many friends and colleagues who have gotten those sorts of emails and have also had them sent from them, supposedly, to their underlings, because in that case, all you
如果你在一个组织里工作，你很可能已经收到了来自公司CEO、总裁或部门主管的电子邮件，说，嘿，我在开会，但我需要你敲定这笔交易，或者如果你恰好是经常收到这类消息或电子邮件的业务经理，你需要尽快支付这张发票，你可能不会三思而后行。但是一旦企业电子邮件遭到泄露，他们就知道该以正确的方式发送给谁，这就很难让人产生怀疑了。我有很多朋友和同事都收到过这类电子邮件，而且据说这些邮件也是从他们那里发送给他们的下属的，因为在这种情况下，你所需要做的
have to do is send a message that looks like it's from the right person and have it happen to go to the right person. And one way to do that is to send a ton of messages, and all you need is a couple of them to go through out of every thousand, and you're still going to profit from it without having to do any work at all. I understand that you once clicked on a link without thinking about whether the link was a fishing or a hacking attempt. Tell me what happened there. Right, I got a message from a friend, a close friend, who had emailed me in the past
就是发送一条看起来像是来自合适的人的消息，并碰巧发给合适的人。而做到这一点的方法之一就是发送大量的消息，你所需要的只是每千条消息中有一两条能成功发送，你仍然可以从中获利，而根本不需要做任何工作。据我了解，你曾经在没有考虑这个链接是钓鱼还是黑客攻击的情况下点击了一个链接。告诉我那里发生了什么。没错，我收到了一条来自朋友的消息，一个老朋友，他在过去
when they'd seen me on TV, on some interview or something. And the message was, hey, I saw you in this video with a link. So in this case, I didn't think twice about it. Oh, I wonder what video they saw. Click. And almost immediately I realized, wait, that probably wasn't legitimate. Probably there account has been hacked and it was sending emails to everybody in their address book.
当他在电视上看到我的一些采访或其他节目时给我发过电子邮件。那条消息是，嘿我在这个视频里看到你了，还附带了一个链接。所以在这种情况下，我没有三思。哦，不知道他们看到了什么视频。点击。几乎立刻我意识到，等等，那可能不是合法的。可能他们的账户被黑了，正在向他们地址簿里的每个人发送电子邮件。
And I just happened to be the one who sometimes is on videos, right? And I was the target, just like that business manager who pays the invoices was the target. Fortunately, I realized it quickly and quickly changed all my passwords and I was fine. But if you are target in the right ways that appeal to the right information to things you're looking for and predict and expect to have happen, you can fall for it. When we come back, other techniques to combat our propensity to fall for scams. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
而我刚好是那个有时会出现在视频里的人，对吧？我就是那个目标，就像那个支付发票的业务经理一样。幸运的是，我很快意识到这一点，并迅速更改了我所有的密码，我没事。但如果你是以正确的方式成为目标，迎合了正确的信息、你正在寻找的事物以及预测和期望发生的事情，你就会上当受骗。当我们回来时，还有其他技术可以对抗我们容易上当受骗的倾向。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Psychologists Dan Simons and Christopher Shabri are co-authors of the book Nobody's Full, why we get taken in and what we can do about it. They've explored a number of different scams, but also ways to spot scams and to protect ourselves. Dan in 1943, US warplanes conducted a raid over Nazi Germany, but of the 291 B-17 bombers taking off from Britain only 33 return undamaged. Tell me the story of what happened and the important scientific principle that the story produced. This is a story about a prominent statistician, Abraham Wald, sort of a statistics
心理学家丹·西蒙斯和克里斯托弗·夏布里是《没人是傻瓜：我们为什么会被骗以及我们能做些什么》一书的合著者。他们探讨了许多不同的骗局，以及发现骗局和保护我们自己的方法。丹，1943年，美国战机对纳粹德国进行了突袭，但在从英国起飞的291架B-17轰炸机中，只有33架完好无损地返回。请告诉我发生了什么故事，以及这个故事所产生的重要的科学原理。这是一个关于杰出统计学家亚伯拉罕·瓦尔德的故事，他可以说是统计学方面的
prodigy. And in 1943 what the military needed to try and figure out was, is there something they could do to help these planes survive? Because it's obviously very costly to lose that many planes on a mission. So the question they asked Wald was, how could we, say, reinforce the planes to prevent the damage from taking them down? So they sent Wald, all of the evidence that they had from all of these damaged planes that they'd gotten, looking at where they'd been hit by the anti-aircraft fire and flack.
奇才。1943年，军方需要弄清楚的是，有没有什么事情是他们可以做来帮助这些飞机生存下来的？因为在一次任务中损失那么多飞机显然代价非常高昂。所以他们向瓦尔德提出的问题是，我们该如何，比如说，加固飞机以防止损害导致它们坠毁？于是他们把从所有这些受损飞机上收集到的所有证据都送给了瓦尔德，观察它们被防空炮火和高射炮击中的地方。
And he did an analysis where he looked at where the planes had been hit as a function of how big the area of the planes were. So the bigger the area of the plane, the more times it should be hit if the damage is just random. And the question was, is the damage random? Or is there something systematic about it? If it's random, you're kind of out of luck, because you can't reinforce the whole plane, it becomes too heavy, can't travel as far, has to carry more fuel, can't carry as much munitions, so it doesn't work. So the hope is that you could reinforce parts of the planes in a way that would increase their survivorship.
他做了一项分析，研究了飞机被击中的位置与飞机面积大小的关系。因此，如果损害只是随机的，飞机的面积越大，它被击中的次数就应该越多。问题是，损害是随机的吗？还是有什么系统性的规律？如果是随机的，那你可能就不走运了，因为你不能加固整架飞机，那样飞机就会变得太重，飞不了那么远，必须携带更多的燃油，不能携带那么多的弹药，所以行不通。因此，希望是以某种方式加固飞机的某些部位，从而提高它们的存活率。
So while did some very sophisticated analyses that are actually still in use today in statistics, and what he showed was that the damage wasn't random. Some areas of the planes were more damaged than others, and more damage than you would expect based on how big they were. So the take home message that you might take from while's analysis is, oh, okay, hey, let's say the fuselage was damaged more than you'd expect by, hey, let's say the fuselage was damaged more than you'd expect by chance. So let's reinforce the fuselage.
因此，瓦尔德做了一些非常复杂的分析，这些分析实际上至今仍在统计学中使用，他表明损害并非随机的。飞机的某些区域比其他区域受损更严重，并且比根据其大小预期的受损程度还要严重。所以你从瓦尔德的分析中可能得出的核心结论是，哦，好吧，比方说，机身受损的程度比你偶然预期的要大。所以让我们加固机身。
Because you can see that's where all the Schrapnil and the anti-acraft gunfire is going. Yeah, but if you did that, you would have done exactly the wrong thing. And the reason for that is we think about the evidence we have right in front of us. Which is all of these damaged planes and all how much they've been shot up. But the parts on the planes that were damaged on those planes that survived, presumably weren't critical to the planes surviving. They could get hit there a lot of times and they still made it back. What you have to think about are the planes that didn't return. The ones that you don't have any data from, and what you should do instead of reinforcing those
因为你可以看到所有的弹片和高射炮火都打在那里。是的，但如果你那样做了，你就完全做错了。原因是我们考虑的是摆在我们面前的证据。也就是所有这些受损飞机以及它们被击毁的程度。但那些幸存飞机上受损的部件，大概对飞机的生存并不是至关重要的。它们在那里可以被击中很多次，而且它们还是飞回来了。你必须考虑的是那些没有回来的飞机。那些你没有任何数据的飞机，你该做的事情不是加固那些
areas that were damaged a lot, is reinforce areas that were almost never damaged on the returning planes, because presumably that's where the planes that were shot down were hit. That's where the planes that were shot down were hit. So, this is a principal habit that we call focus. We tend to focus on the information we have right in front of us, and we tend not to think about what information we're missing. In this case, in order to make the right decisions, you have to think not just about the planes you have, but about all of the planes that went down
受损严重的区域，而是加固返回的飞机上几乎从未受损的区域，因为据推测，被击落的飞机就是那些地方被击中了。那就是被击落的飞机被击中的地方。所以，这是一个我们称之为“聚焦”的主要习惯。我们倾向于关注摆在我们面前的信息，而往往不考虑我们缺少什么信息。在这种情况下，为了做出正确的决定，你不仅要考虑你拥有的飞机，还要考虑所有坠毁的飞机
and where they were likely to have been hit. And Walt, of course, didn't make this mistake. Walt knew what he was doing. There's a sort of like-the-invisible gorilla experiment in some ways, which is you're so focused on counting the passes among the people passing the basketball that you fail to notice the person in the gorilla suit. That's exactly right. It's a form of focus,
以及它们可能在哪个部位被击中。当然，瓦尔德并没有犯这个错误。瓦尔德知道自己在做什么。这在某种程度上有点像“隐形大猩猩”实验，也就是说你太专注于数传篮球的人之间的传球次数，以至于你没有注意到穿大猩猩服装的人。完全正确。这是一种聚焦形式，
it's the same sort of idea. That's a visual form of focus, whereas we can have a thinking form of focus, where we focus on some information and not other information. But the real parallel there isn't just that focusing on some things and ignoring others. It's that our intuitions are wrong. So in the Gorilla basketball video, if I showed you that video and you didn't happen to see the gorilla, and I never asked you about a gorilla. You continue going through life, assuming that of course you would see a person in a gorilla suit, right?
这和那种想法是一样的。这是一种视觉上的聚焦，而我们也可以有一种思考上的聚焦，即我们专注于某些信息而不关注其他信息。但真正的相似之处不仅仅在于关注某些事情而忽略其他事情。而是我们的直觉是错的。所以在猩猩篮球视频中碰巧没看到猩猩，我也从不问你关于猩猩的事。你继续过着你的生活，假设你当然会看到一个穿大猩猩服装的人，对吧？
Because we're not aware of the amount of things we miss. We're only aware of the things we noticed. So we build up this intuitive experience that, hey, all these things I've noticed, that's what builds your intuition. The things you didn't notice don't build up your intuitions. And that works well most of the time, but it also allows us to be fooled really easily.
因为我们没有意识到我们错过了多少事情。我们只知道我们注意到的事情。所以我们建立了一种直观的体验，嘿，所有这些我注意到的事情，这就是构建你直觉的东西。你没有注意到的事情不会建立你的直觉。这种方法在大多数时候都管用，但它也让我们很容易被愚弄。
So we're in the domain now of, I'm not sure we should call these scams necessarily, because when you have a scam, usually you have someone who is trying to fool you, or trying to pull the wool over your eyes. But in many ways, these are really important distortions in daily life, because I see stories all the time that say, think about people like Bill Gates and Steve Jobs and Mark Zuckerberg.
所以我们现在讨论的领域，我不确定我们是否一定应该称这些为骗局，因为当你遇到骗局时，通常会有人试图愚弄你，或者试图瞒过你的眼睛。但在许多方面，这些确实是日常生活中的重要扭曲，因为我经常看到一些故事，说想想比尔·盖茨、史蒂夫·乔布斯和马克·扎克伯格这样的人。
They dropped out of college how valuable could it be to go to college? And in some ways, that's like the story of the B-17 bombers. Yeah, because you have to think about you're only getting those cases right in front of you. You've got the Bill Gates and Mark Zuckerberg cases. But in order to know whether college matters for success, you have to look not just at those three examples, which are prominent examples of not going to college, but think about what percentage of CEOs of those sort of billion-dollar trillion-dollar companies actually dropped out, and what
他们从大学辍学了，上大学到底能有什么价值？在某些方面，这就像B-17轰炸机的故事。是的，因为你必须考虑到你得到的只是眼前的那些案例。你有比尔·盖茨和马克·扎克伯格的案例。但为了知道大学对成功是否重要，你不仅要看那三个不上大学的突出例子，还要考虑那些价值数十亿数万亿美元的公司的CEO中，究竟有多少比例的人退学了，以及
percentage of them went to college. And if you actually do that, the vast majority of these sort of unicorn companies that were successful quickly with a very large value, almost all of the CEOs of those companies not only went to college, many of them went to graduate school. So to think about the evidence, you actually need to think about the rate, how often and how often did they not do that to get a sense of whether it's important. And that's one thing that's really hard for us because we love success stories. Hey, here's Bill Gates, he was so successful.
有多少比例的人上了大学。如果你真的去做了，你会发现这些迅速成功且价值巨大的独角兽公司中，绝大多数CEO不仅上了大学，而且许多人还读了研究生。因此，要思考证据，你实际上需要思考比率，即他们有多大频率没有这样做，从而来判断它是否重要。这对我们来说确实很难，因为我们喜欢成功的故事。嘿，这是比尔·盖茨，他太成功了。
Let's look at all of the things he did in his past and then maybe emulate them. But the thing you have to keep in mind is, okay, yeah, he did those things. But how many other people did those things and failed miserably? And how many people did other things and succeeded? And how many people did those things and failed miserably. And how many people did other things and succeeded. And how many people did other things and failed miserably.
让我们看看他过去做过所有的事情，然后也许效仿它们。但你必须记住的是，好吧，是的，他做了那些事情。但有多少其他人也做了那些事情却惨遭失败？有多少人做了别的事情却成功了？有多少人做了那些事情却惨遭失败。有多少人做了别的事情却成功了。有多少人做了别的事情却惨遭失败。
And it may turn out that things he did are the worst things that you could possibly do and he just got really, really lucky. And we don't know that unless we think about the evidence we don't have, the things we're not focusing on. So Dan, we talked earlier about the story of Bernie Madoff, and we talked about how part of the seductiveness of that story was that he was offering returns that were extremely predictable, not necessarily sky-high returns, but very predictable returns.
事实证明，他做的事情可能是你所能做的最糟糕的事情，而他只是非常非常幸运。除非我们考虑我们没有的证据、我们没有关注的事情，否则我们是不会知道这一点的。所以，丹，我们之前讨论过伯尼·马道夫的故事，我们讨论过这个故事之所以诱人，部分原因是他提供的回报极其可预测，不一定是天文数字般的回报，但却是非常可预测的回报。
Talk about why consistency in what we see Dan and A.O.T. can sometimes be a flag that what we're seeing is problematic. Yeah, so consistency is something that we call a hook and hooks are kinds of information that we find appealing in part because consistency usually is a sign that somebody has a great understanding in order to be able to produce the same level of performance over and over and over again. So usually consistency is a great thing if you can get the same scientific result over and over and over again. That means you is a great thing. If you can get the same scientific result over and over and over again, that means you probably have a pretty good understanding
谈谈为什么我们在丹和A.O.T.身上看到的这种一致性有时会成为一个危险信号，表明我们所看到的是有问题的。是的，所以一致性是我们所说的一个“钩子”，钩子是我们觉得有吸引力的信息，部分原因是一致性通常表明某人有极好的理解力，能够一次又一次、一遍又一遍地产生相同的表现水平。所以通常情况下，如果你能一次又一次、一遍又一遍地得到相同的科学结果，一致性是一件好事。这意味着你是一件好事。如果你能一次又一次、一遍又一遍地得到相同的科学结果，这意味着你可能对
of how it works. The problem comes in when people use that consistency as a tool to deceive us. So scientific fraudsters will also produce the same result over and over and over again, with almost no variability or almost no noise in their outcomes. And in normal science, that's a great sign.
它是如何运作的有一个相当好的理解。问题出现在人们利用这种一致性作为欺骗我们的工具时。因此，科学骗子也会一次又一次地产生相同的结果，他们的结果中几乎没有变异性，也没有噪音。在正常科学中，这是一个好迹象。
In fraudulent science, it's a red flag. It's a problem. And sometimes the consistency is so great that it makes it implausible that it could be real. Bernie Madoff's case, the consistent returns he offered of that 8-14% were impossibly consistent. If you look at all other sorts of money-managing funds, anything that's producing returns of like 8% to 14% over that time window would have a lot of variability.
在欺骗性科学中，这是一个危险信号。这是一个问题。有时这种一致性太好了，以至于让人觉得它不可能是真的。在伯尼·马道夫的案子中，他提供的8%-14%的持续回报率是不可能保持一致的。如果你看看所有其他类型的资金管理基金，任何在那个时间窗口内产生8%到14%左右回报的基金都会有很大的变异性。
Some years would be up 20%, some years would be down close to 20%. It would bounce around. And that's true of almost any complex human-driven activity, including big systems like the stock market that involve a lot of moving parts. You want there to be that volatility because it's what happens in any sort of natural system. And when it's missing, then you've got to worry. It's interesting throughout our lives in so many different ways. We value and demand consistency from others. It's not just when it comes to investments, when it comes to friends, partners, co-workers, consistency is always seen as something that's good. But of course, it is. We know from So it's not just when it comes to investments, when it comes to friends, partners, coworkers,
有些年份会上升20%，有些年份会下跌接近20%。它会上下波动。几乎任何复杂的由人类驱动的活动都是如此，包括涉及许多活动部件的大型系统，比如股票市场。你希望有这种波动性，因为这是任何自然系统中都会发生的事情。当它消失时，你就要担心了。有趣的是，在我们一生中的许多不同方式中。我们重视并要求他人保持一致。不仅在投资方面，在朋友、伴侣、同事方面，一致性总是被视为一件好事。当然，它是。我们从所以不仅仅是在投资方面，在朋友、伴侣、同事方面，
you know, consistency is always seen as something that's good. But of course, it is. We know from our own lives, when we think about ourselves, you know, we're up one day, we're down the next, you know, things change. Yeah, absolutely. But consistency is a good thing, right? And that's the thing that in reviewing all of these scams
你知道的，一致性总是被视为一件好事。但当然，它是。我们从我们自己的生活中知道，当我们想到自己的时候，你知道的，我们有时状态好，有时状态糟，你知道的，事情在变。是的，绝对的。但一致性是一件好事，对吧？这就是你在回顾所有这些骗局时发现的
and cons from so many different areas that you realize is all of them take advantage of habits that we have that usually serve us really well. So things like consistency are usually a great sign of understanding. Things like familiarity, knowing that people around you and trusting them more, is usually a great thing to do because we've built up relationships. Usually if somebody produces a result that's really, really precise, that's a sign that they have a great understanding of how to do it. If they can make a really good accurate prediction
来自许多不同领域的骗局，你会意识到所有这些骗局都利用了我们通常对我们很有帮助的习惯。因此，诸如一致性之类的事情通常是理解力的绝佳标志。诸如熟悉感、了解周围的人并更信任他们之类的事情通常是一件好事，因为我们已经建立了关系。通常，如果有人产生了一个非常非常精确的结果，这表明他们对如何做到这一点有很好的理解。如果他们能做出非常准确的预测
and say, it's going to rain at 135 today, and it does, wow, their model must be really good. But somebody who's trying to fool us or trying to deceive us is going to use exactly those same sorts of clues to good things, but to hide what they're actually doing. In our current times, not just in the United States, but in many countries around the world, we live in a hyper partisan era where people are deeply connected to their political parties
并说，今天下午1点35分会下雨，结果确实下了，哇，他们的模型一定非常好。但是一个试图愚弄我们或试图欺骗我们的人会完全利用这些同样的好迹象的线索，来隐藏他们实际在做的事情。在当前时代，不仅在美国，而且在世界许多国家，我们生活在一个高度极化的时代，人们与他们的政党紧密相连，
and deeply antagonistic to what their opponents. And all of us are extremely vigilant to misinformation and disinformation on the side of our opponents. Any of us can look at people who don't belong to our political party and say these people are idiots, how can they possibly believe what they believe? Can you talk a moment about the role of partisanship in our ability to be taken in by misinformation and scams? Yeah, I think partisanship of that extreme form relies on a couple of different habits we have
并且对他们的对手深恶痛绝。我们所有人都对对手那边的错误信息和虚假信息高度警惕。我们中的任何一个人都可以看着不属于我们政党的人说这些人是白痴，他们怎么可能相信他们所相信的东西？你能谈谈党派之争在我们容易被错误信息和骗局欺骗的能力中所起的作用吗？是的，我认为这种极端形式的党派之争依赖于我们的一些不同习惯，
that lead us to have a very hard time taking a step back and viewing things from a different perspective. So one of them is a commitment to the belief that your side is in the right. And that can take the form of idolizing a political figure and thinking they can do no wrong to assuming that the other side's agenda must be malicious. But whatever that assumption is,
这些习惯导致我们很难退后一步，从不同的角度来看待事物。其中之一就是坚信你的立场是正确的。这可以采取偶像化政治人物并认为他们不会犯错的形式，也可以采取假设对手的议程必然是恶意的形式。但无论这种假设是什么，
once you've held onto it so firmly that you don't question it, it becomes a commitment, then you can think incredibly logically about all of the evidence you're seeing, but it's always going to be twisted by that initial assumption. It's in many ways the way cults work, right? If you start with a premise that the cult leader is infallible, or a super genius, or everything that they say must be true, then they can lead you down a path of doing stranger and
一旦你坚定地抱着它而不去质疑它，它就会变成一种承诺，然后你可以对你所看到的所有的证据进行难以置信的逻辑思考，但它总是会被最初的那个假设所扭曲。这在很多方面就是邪教运作的方式，对吧？如果你从这样一个前提开始，即邪教领袖是不会犯错的，或者是个超级天才，或者他们说的每件事都必须是真的，那么他们就可以引导你走向做越来越奇怪的事情的道路，
stranger things because you have to make them consistent with that initial assumption. From the outside, people in a cult are doing some really bizarre things from the inside, they're completely logical and coherent. And as you said, we're all great at tearing apart beliefs we disagree with. When you get some information, somebody passes along something that they're sharing that you completely disagree with because you're coming from the other side of it.
因为你必须让它们与最初的那个假设保持一致。从外部来看，邪教中的人们正在做一些非常怪异的事情，但从内部来看，它们完全符合逻辑且连贯。正如你所说，我们都很擅长剖析我们不同意的信仰。当你得到一些信息时，有人传递了一些他们分享的东西，而你完全不同意，因为你是从它的另一面来看待的。
It's really easy to take it apart. We have a much harder time doing that about things that we do believe. And it can lead us to actually being fooled by misinformation that's consistent with our beliefs. I don't know if you recall this, but I think during the 2016 presidential election, you know, there were reports of hacking where supporters of the Democratic candidate Hillary Clinton were told, you know, you can't really trust the system.
剖析它真的很容易。对于我们确实相信的事情，我们要做到这一点要困难得多。这可能会导致我们实际上被符合我们信仰的错误信息所欺骗。我不知道你是否还记得，但我认为在2016年总统大选期间，你知道，有报道称发生了黑客攻击，民主党候选人希拉里·克林顿的支持者被告知，你知道，你真的不能相信这个体制。
The system is really rigged against you. Powerful special interests are taking over the country. Why bother showing up to vote on election day? The idea really was that something that Knight-Nate Peel to people with a progressive bent of sort of saying there are powerful special interests that are controlling everything. Ordinary people have much less of a say.
这个体制真的对你不利。强大的特殊利益集团正在接管这个国家。为什么还要费心在选举日出现去投票呢？这个想法其实是，某种能够吸引具有进步倾向的人的东西，比如说有强大的特殊利益集团在控制一切。普通人的发言权要少得多。
But you're using that message to basically encourage people not to show up to vote, which might actually not be in their, in their best interest. If I'm an, a political operative, rather than tell you about the beliefs about your political opponents, which you're going to shoot down in a heartbeat, it's almost easier to come from the other end of the spectrum and reinforce what you already believe and try and twist that to get me what I want you to do. Yeah, now I think that's exactly right. There's a lot of the time what people will try and do is tap into other beliefs that are maybe tangential to the ones that you're actually
但你利用这个信息基本上是为了鼓励人们不要去投票，这实际上可能并不符合他们的最大利益。如果我是一个政治特工，比起向你讲述关于你政治对手的信仰（你会毫不犹豫地将其反驳），从另一个极端出发来强化你已经相信的东西，并试图扭转这一点以达到我想要你做的事情，几乎更容易。是的，现在我认为这完全正确。很多时候，人们会尝试做的是利用其他一些信仰，这些信仰可能与你真正试图指导的信仰切题，
trying to direct as a way of sort of building up a sense of trust and building up a sense of agreement. Standard technique and persuasion, right? You get people to agree with things that are tangential to the thing that you really want to persuade them of and only come out them for the exact demand later. So this is something that's used, for example, in some of the crypto scams. One of the hallmarks of crypto currencies is that they have this feel of being anti-establishment anti-government, trying to tap into people who might be distrusting of institutions as a way of getting them to invest in crypto, which is probably something they shouldn't be doing. You know, very often, Dan, when I read stories about a scam, when I read about the Bernie Madoff scam or what happened with Theranos, there's a part of me
以此作为建立信任感和建立共识的一种方式。说服的标准技术，对吧？你让人们同意那些与你真正想说服他们的事情切题的事情，然后只在稍后才对他们提出确切的要求。所以这是在一些加密货币骗局中使用的东西。加密货币的一个标志是它们有一种反建制、反政府的感觉，试图利用那些可能对机构不信任的人，以此来诱使他们投资加密货币，而这可能是不应该做的事情。你知道，很多时候，丹，当我读到关于骗局的故事时，当我读到伯尼·马总骗局或Theranos发生了什么时，我内心的一部分
that says, how could people have been so dumb. How could they have fallen for this too good to be true story? Talk about how our belief that we can spot scammers is part of the advantage that scammers have over us. Yeah. So the idea that if something is too good to be true, it probably is, sounds great in principle, but the reason we come to this mistaken belief that only gullible people, or clueless people, or the hopelessly naive people fall for these sorts of scams, is that we usually only hear about them and view them from the outside, either in hindsight, or watching in the moment and knowing that it's a scam.
就会说，人们怎么会这么愚蠢。他们怎么会落入这个好得令人难以置信的故事中？谈谈我们认为自己能够识别骗子的信念，是如何成为骗子对我们占优势的一部分的。是的。因此，“如果某事好得令人难以置信，那它可能就是假的”这个观点在原则上听起来很棒，但我们之所以产生这种错误的信念，即只有轻信的人、毫无头绪的人或无可救药的天真之人才会落入这类骗局，是因为我们通常只在事后，或者在当下观看并知道这是一个骗局的情况下，从外部听到和看到它们。
So if you're watching a great movie about a con artist, you know that they're a con artist. You can see how they're manipulating people because you're not immersed in it. You're not part of the story. They're not taking advantage of you and feeding you those kinds of information you find appealing. But the way scams and cons work is they take advantage of those cognitive tendencies
所以如果你在看一部关于骗子的精彩电影，你知道他们是骗子。你能看出他们是如何操纵人们的，因为你没有沉浸其中。你不是故事的一部分。他们没有利用你并向你喂食你觉得有吸引力的那种信息。但骗局运作的方式是利用这些认知倾向
to target you. And all of us can be victimized by this, no matter how cynical or skeptical or clear thinking you think you are, we all will fall for the right scam and the right sort of targeting. Here's a great one in a terrible way, of course, but here's a great one that targets professors. So professors often are giving toxic conferences, and quite often the arrangements for those sorts of conferences are made by the conference organizers.
来针对你。我们所有人都会成为这方面的受害者，无论你认为自己多么愤世嫉俗、怀疑或思路清晰，只要遇到合适的骗局和合适的针对目标，我们所有人都会上当受骗。这里有一个很好的例子，当然是以一种糟糕的方式，但这里有一个很好的针对教授的例子。所以教授经常做有毒的会议，而且通常这些会议的安排都是由会议组织者完成的。
So the organizers will book the hotel room, they might book the travel, and academics who do a lot of traveling are used to this. What normally happens though is you're working directly with the conference organizers, but sometimes you'll work with the travel agency that will handle it. Normally when that happens, the organizers will tell you to call the travel agency and make the reservations. So what happens when the travel agency calls you and you're busy and you don't think much about it? They call and say, hey, we're working on behalf of the conference organizers and we're booking
因此，组织者会预订酒店房间，他们可能会预订行程，经常旅行的学者对此已经习惯了。然而，通常发生的情况是，你直接与会议组织者合作，但有时你会与处理这件事的旅行社合作。通常情况下，组织者会告诉你打电话给旅行社并进行预订。那么，当旅行社打电话给你，而你很忙，并且没有多想时会发生什么？他们打电话说，嘿，我们代表会议组织者工作，我们正在预订
your hotel and your travel. So what's your frequent flyer number? What's your preferred type of room? And why don't you give us your credit card so we can put that down for incidentals at the hotel. And they've just stolen your identity. Because they aren't actually the conference organizers. The scammers just look at who's speaking at the conference and call all the speakers. And you should be never, ever giving credit card information to anybody over the phone if they called you ever. Because that's the entry point for a scam. I'm wondering after doing a lot of this research and thinking about all these scams,
你的酒店和行程。那么你的常客飞行常客证号是多少？你喜欢什么类型的房间？你为什么不把你的信用卡给我们，以便我们可以把它记在酒店的杂费里。他们刚刚窃取了你的身份。因为他们实际上不是会议组织者。骗子只是看看谁在会议上发言，然后给所有发言者打电话。而且你绝不应该在电话里向任何人透露信用卡信息，如果他们给你打电话的话。因为那是骗局的入口。我在想，在做了大量这项研究并思考了所有这些骗局之后，
are you sort of walking around being hyper-synical and skeptical all the time, Dan? I hope not. We have to believe that other people are being truthful with us. Most of the time, you can't have a world in which you distrust everything you encounter. It wouldn't be productive. We couldn't hold a conversation. We couldn't have a society. We have to be trusting to some extent. And the key is trying to figure out when to be skeptical and critical and when not to be. So the message is to try and identify those cases when you're at serious risk and think about, if I were a scammer, how would I take advantage of somebody right now? Or you get an offer that sounds good. Ask yourself, okay, if I were trying to scam me, how would I do it? Asking that question allows you to ask more questions.
丹，你是不是一直表现得超级愤世嫉俗和怀疑？我希望没有。我们必须相信其他人对我们说的是实话。大多数时候，你不可能生活在一个你对遇到的每件事都怀疑的世界里。那将是没有成效的。我们无法进行对话。我们无法拥有一个社会。我们在某种程度上必须是信任的。关键是试图弄清楚什么时候该保持怀疑和批判，什么时候不该。所以这个信息是试图识别那些你处于严重风险中的情况，并思考，如果我是个骗子，我现在会如何利用某人？或者你得到了一个听起来不错的报价。问问你自己，好吧，如果我想骗我，我会怎么做？问这个问题可以让你问更多的问题。
Well, so much of the message of this book, as I think perhaps with much of your field, then, is the message of humility and sort of the idea that we should in fact be cautious about leaping to conclusions and we should be cautious about the things that we feel certain about. Do you feel like this fits in with sort of that larger message that in some ways we should actually be more humble about the things we know and the things we think we know? Yeah, I mean, I think the thing to trust, I trust experts who say I don't know, that's a good thing. People who have been very successful in their lives tend to assume that they can read other people, that they can judge the situation
嗯，这本书的很多信息，正如我认为可能你的领域的很多信息一样，然后，是谦逊的信息，以及我们实际上应该对仓促下结论保持谨慎的想法，我们应该对我们确信的事情保持谨慎。你觉得这符合那种更大的信息吗，即在某些方面我们实际上应该对我们所知道的事情和我们认为我们知道的事情更加谦虚？是的，我的意思是，我认为要信任的事情，我信任那些说“我不知道”的专家，这是一件好事。那些在生活中非常成功的人往往认为他们可以看穿其他人，他们可以判断局势
and they go with their gut. And that's how they get taken for big dollars because they assume that they would spot those red flags because they're only aware of the grillas they've seen. Right, they're not aware of all of the ones that they missed. They're not aware of the planes that didn't come back. They're not paying attention to those.
并且他们跟着自己的直觉走。这就是他们被骗走大笔资金的原因，因为他们认为他们会发现这些危险信号，因为他们只知道他们见过的大猩猩。对吧，他们没有意识到所有他们错过的东西。他们没有意识到没有回来的飞机。他们没有注意到这些。
The metaphor I really like for this is of a bullfighter, Matador. And a Matador shows this red cape to the bull, and the bull finds it irresistible. They charge that red cape, not realizing that there's a blade behind it. Well, the sorts of information hooks that we find really appealing, that consistency,
我真正喜欢的这个比喻是斗牛士。斗牛士向公牛展示这件红斗篷，公牛觉得它不可抗拒。它们冲向那件红斗篷，却没有意识到后面有一把刀。好吧，我们觉得非常有吸引力的那种信息钩子，那种一致性，
the really potent things, the familiarity, are the sorts of things that lead us to charge right in without stopping to think. And those are the times we really need to stop and ask more questions. Dan Simons is a psychologist at the University of Illinois, or Bana Champagne. Along with psychologist Christopher Shabrie, he is the co-author of the book, Nobody's Fool, why we get taken in and what we can do about it, and the invisible gorilla, how our intuitions deceive us. Dan, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me on, it was a fun conversation. Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me on.
那些非常强大的东西，熟悉感，就是那些引导我们不假思索地直接冲进去的东西。而这些正是我们需要真正停下来提出更多问题的时候。丹·西蒙斯是厄巴纳-尚佩恩伊利诺伊大学的心理学家。他和心理学家克里斯托弗·夏布里是《没人是傻瓜：我们为什么会被骗以及我们能做些什么》以及《隐形大猩猩：我们的直觉如何欺诈我们》的合著者。丹，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我，这是一场有趣的对话。《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。
It was a fun conversation. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's Executive Editor. Special thanks this week to Sound Designer Nick Woodbury. Our Ronson Hero this week is Taylor Bernie. Taylor is the director of Network
这是一场有趣的对话。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周特别感谢声音设计师尼克·伍德伯里。我们本周的朗森英雄是泰勒·伯尼。泰勒是NPR网络
Programming and Production at NPR. Hidden Brain's radio show is distributed by NPR and there are many different tasks involved in making sure public radio shows run smoothly. Taylor communicates early and often about upcoming deadlines and offers helpful clear suggestions when we are prepping shows for public radio fundraising campaigns. Thanks for everything you do behind the scenes to help us out, Taylor. If you know someone who would find today's episode to be interesting or useful, please
编程和制作的总监。《隐藏的大脑》的广播节目由NPR分发，确保公共广播节目顺利运行涉及许多不同的任务。泰勒就即将到来的截止日期进行早期和频繁的沟通，并在我们为公共广播筹款活动筹备节目时提供有益、清晰的建议。谢谢你为我们幕后所做的一切，泰勒。如果你认识某人会觉得今天的这一集有趣或有用，请
share it with them. Recommendations from our audience are one of the best ways to connect new listeners to the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与他们分享。来自我们听众的推荐是将新听众与我们在《隐藏的大脑》中探讨的想法联系起来的最佳方式之一。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。